and we're back and the studio is gone
well
you know
yeah we're in in the middle of the move
today the truck comes and uh gonna move
some of the big stuff
but this place here has all been moved
to the new place yes so sorry it sounds
a bit echoey because a lot of stuff is
like we took a bunch of stuff off the
walls and all the books are gone and
stuff i know it looks really weird we've
got the new studio painted and
everything it's darker version of gray
we think it'll work out better with the
lights i think it's gonna be good yeah
it'll be nice so yeah like i said um so
we're gonna be
if we stream
because this we're recording this on
wednesday
um
and then
we're gonna stream probably from here on
friday night like we usually would
we might do a stream on sunday because
it's my birthday but other than that
it's um we probably won't be streaming
from the new house until next wednesday
yeah you know what i mean like for the
sidetrack show but all the recorded
stuff should
still be going up uh in a normal timely
fashion because this is pretty much the
only thing we have to record i have to
record a couple things but i can do that
so yeah so those out tonight yeah those
uh those old bookshelves are getting
thrown out yeah so sorry it sounds a
little echoey sorry it looks a little
naked back there conan's still there and
the button and the robots are still
there but uh yeah all the other stuff's
at the new house so
that aside let's talk about edward
scissorhands yeah i haven't seen this in
a long time i hadn't seen this one
either and it's really funny because i
remember seeing it a bunch like back in
the day it came out in 1990 like late
1990 and i remember really liking it but
i think i was like oh well i still like
beetlejuice better but when i was
watching edward scissorhands again and i
probably hadn't seen it for at least 10
years maybe 15 and i was like man i
forgot how [ __ ] good this movie is i
forgot how gothic it was
well yeah well all his stuff is like
very it was just funny
it's funny for like people that um that
kind of grew up with tim burton and
everything like that but it's just like
when tim burton came on the scene you
know we were teenagers or you know early
so to see somebody like a big time
director making movies like that with
that aesthetic was like kind of
mind-blowing you know what i mean we had
never really seen much of anything like
that before this movie is actually kind
of like a kind of like an analogy
for uh growing up as a goth kid in a
normal neighborhood yeah well that's
exactly what's exactly what that
character is representing at the time
i didn't get it as much
because i couldn't grasp the adult
perspective of the the adults in the in
in in this in the story yeah you know
what i mean so
i could kind of get the the edward
scissorhands character but i didn't
really get the adults
and
as i've as i've aged
i kind of gained a different perspective
of this movie it's pretty good like uh
he comes out of the castle and he's like
and hang it and an older woman finds him
and she's
she's cute and her husband's kind of
i would say i would say he's kind of
like physically a has-been and she's
just kind of into this young guy she's
cougar and all over him
[Laughter]
and uh
all her friends are [ __ ] jealous of
her and they start competing for this
young
goth dude you know johnny depp he's in
his [ __ ] prime in this his most
gothiness deputy of deafiness
actually he's not actually the top the
the the maximum depth yeah he hasn't
reached the maximum depth he's not the
johnny depp that you've known he's still
quite young and then he's real young but
he's he's he's coming there
but it's just so funny because like one
of the characters
at the time you know hurt one of her
friends is this [ __ ] redhead
who's always trying to put the moves on
[ __ ] all the maintenance men and [ __ ]
that she hires to come in the house
and at the time i just
being a kid i just saw her as looking
kind of an old lady but you see her now
she's looking hot as hell smoking hot
running after it i was like oh damn i
didn't really yeah she's like a peg
bundy type kind of like a peg bunny yeah
she's sucking smoking hot in it played
by kathy baker and i think this was her
first comedic role she wanted to do it
because she had previously just done
like dramas up to this point i believe
uh so she wanted to kind of be funny and
she's great in this like her character
name is joyce
so
yeah everything in the movie [ __ ]
holds up man this movie holds up it
really does and and like i said i
actually this is one of those movies
that like i said i really really liked
it back in the day but i was like oh i
think i liked some of his other movies
better but watching this one
recently i was like you know what i
think
this might be tim burton's best movie
uh maybe i mean i don't know he's made a
lot of good ones movies and taxes pretty
damn cool man we got to do mars attacks
at some point too but it's like i don't
know what it is there's just something
like everything about this just came
together in a way that i think
um
didn't for me like exactly like back in
the day like seeing it again like all
the production design the score is
amazing um and danny elfman actually
said i think this is the fourth movie
that um tim burton and danny altman had
done together
but you know and obviously they had a
very long working relationship
i think danny elfman has said if i'm not
mistaken that this was his favorite
score that he ever did and it is a great
[ __ ] score just everything about this
it's just so
i love like the fairy tale feel of it i
love like the old
uh universal monster kind of thing i
love the whole it's you know it's
because it's kind of like a
modernization a little bit of like
frankenstein or like the hunchback of
notre dame or something like that
well that all kind of fit with the motif
because that's what it felt like
[ __ ] being goth at that time it did
yeah it kind of treated you like you
were a monster there was no there was no
uh
uh of social media so it was not
normalized to look
that way to look that way yeah and to be
into that kind of stuff so they kind of
were like
and
and the movie kind of holds up you know
what i mean in terms of like
winona ryder who's she's kind of like
the cool girl you know she's kind of
well she's like a regular cool girl
yeah she's like a little blonde she
doesn't look anything like she looked at
me no she's got us into this alternate
alternative kind of [ __ ]
version of masculine beauty i guess you
know and she's like wow you know what i
mean this guy's different and the
boyfriend wants to beat his ass and they
set him up for all kinds of stuff he
doesn't quite really fit in and
some of the some of the adults
who maybe might have been misfits when
they were younger understand it to kind
of help him out it's just a good story
it's it's the story of a goth kid
really that's what it is yeah retold as
kind of like a universal monster slash
fairy tale this is what it was like when
i was a kid yeah which like i said i
mean tim burton was super into it well
because i mean even when he was like
yeah he made like vincent which is about
vincent price and he you know vincent
price is in this this was his last film
role and that was like a role that he
wrote specifically for him because they
became friends later you know he did
frankenweenie yeah the animated uh you
know stop-motion animation that was all
so he's all into like those old
universal monster movies and stuff which
is like really cool and i like this
little swindle guff well yeah well yeah
the thing about um the edward
scissorhands character i think tim
burton originally drew that character
when he was a teenager
and um you know after he made
uh beetlejuice and after he kind of got
famous like in hollywood he was kind of
like he wanted to make a movie about
this character and he it was him
obviously so he had drawn this little
character and you can see like drawings
of it it's all over the with little
knives for hands and he said that it
kind of represented
you know him growing up in this sort of
faceless suburb in burbank and 50s and
not very well yeah and not really being
able to like fit in although he's not
that old he didn't that much older than
us i think he probably was probably he's
probably 10 years older so he's probably
like 60s or 60s
so he had kind of like
actually no i don't maybe maybe he's not
that much older than us i'm not really
sure 15 years older oh okay but uh the
it is
it the motif for the town is 50s because
i think they're just he's just trying to
let you know that it's just like very
conventional and very very very american
normal like very bland suburbia yeah i
like though that he didn't do he didn't
go exactly the frankenstein route
because it isn't like
um you know and everybody knows the
story of edward scissorhands for
christ's sake but like you know diane
wiest playing the avon lady who goes up
to the house and sees him up there by
himself because the inventor has died
and he comes back down into this like
suburbia and i like that
everyone didn't treat him like a monster
at first
everyone was actually kind of intrigued
by him especially when they
saw what he could do like when they that
he could use his hands to like prune the
hedges and like cut everyone's hair and
groom the dogs and stuff but the thing
about that is that
really they only
liked him when he could do things for
them you know what i mean which is kind
of shitty but like and then as soon as
like something bad happened they all
turned on him and then it became like
frankenstein where they're like you know
with pitchforks and everything
metaphorically
but um
so i like but i like that they made it
like that where it wasn't like he didn't
come down and everyone was like freak
like right away except for the religious
lady but they didn't know what to make
of him yeah they were just kind of like
but but like i said you know because um
diane waste character
peg you know was nice and everybody was
like gossiping about it because they
were fascinated but i think like the
implication there being that this this
suburb was so [ __ ] boring
that when something like came and like
shook it up they were all like wanting
to get in on it type of thing so they
were like ooh here's like the first
interesting thing that's happened here
like forever
um can we talk about that suburb too
because that is an actual real suburb
they didn't build that and you know
where it is it's in lutz which is right
outside of tampa florida i know exactly
where that is uh if you go on wikipedia
it'll tell you what the name of the um
is it still there
as far as i know okay uh as it tells you
like exactly what the um what the
neighborhood is called
but what they did it doesn't really look
exactly like that but they said what
they wanted tim burton wanted to shoot
it in burbank uh but he was like there
wasn't really any suburbs around burbank
where we could shoot that looked the way
i was picturing it or like looked the
way it looked when i was growing up so
they went on a location scouted and they
found this
this suburb outside of tampa and they
said it was just this plain generic
suburb like all the houses looked
exactly the same
and so uh they bet and they they just
painted them like one or one of four
colors they said and the colors were
what were they dirty flesh
butter
dirty blue and one other one i can't
remember what it was like some kind of
weird pink color
um something that got cheap yeah
probably so it's because they wanted it
just to look and i like the way they not
only like did the houses all look the
same but they did these great like uh
these wide shots of like all the cars
like all the husbands going to work
like pulling out of their driveways at
the same time yeah like everyone's
leaving for work at the same time all
the husbands are leaving and then
they're all coming home at the same time
the way it was though yeah and it's just
like it was like really funny that they
that that they didn't really like i just
really like those shots because it's
kind of like subtle but it's like
showing everybody and all the wives stay
home and just like yap on their phones
all that holds true to what i've said
before on the main show
when i said that
florida reminds me of the way california
was growing up when i was growing up
there well even back in 1990 it reminded
me or whenever they were shooting this
yeah well tim burton agreed with me yeah
that florida is a lot like california
used to be yeah um
now
it's a lot it's modern now you know
florida is you know the houses you know
you you see now you know most of them
are less than 10 years old
but um depending on the area
yeah they just open up whole new areas
and let other ones fall apart and they
tear that [ __ ] down and they feel
something else yeah well i do that
everywhere we'll pave this swamp over
over here and build some more houses
but uh most of florida kind of has that
weird [ __ ] mixture of
suburbia and [ __ ]
country kind of way escondido and
oceanside california used to be and
vista you know it was like that
yeah those places are probably all built
up and i haven't seen those since the
1982
yeah you moved away yeah they're
probably [ __ ]
suburban sprawl now yeah this is the way
florida is most of it's kind of like the
way it used to be there so that's i
think it's just an interesting choice
that
burton agreed with yeah i love that they
they i think it took three months to
shoot the movie so i guess they just had
to like kick everybody out of their
houses or
you know it's like hey we'll pay for you
to go stay like in a long-term hotel or
something they had to paint everyone's
houses i think they did other [ __ ] too
like they narrowed the windows and they
did like some other production design
things they might have done some [ __ ]
with their yards and uh so they had to
put it all back like before the people
could move it would have been a low rent
district even back into that area it
probably yeah because the houses don't
look yeah i don't even know like i said
i'm pretty sure it's still there but i
don't know what it looks like it's like
early 60s construction
that was the hood that was the hood it
might be the hood now yeah really good
idea like i said i used to live i've
never been to lutz but i used to live in
tampa so i know where that suburb is
but uh let's talk about johnny depp for
a minute because at this point like i
said you know everybody in the world
[ __ ] knows who johnny depp is but
this was he was kind of famous at this
point but i think he was more known for
being a tv star because he was on 21
jump street right so he was still like
pretty young he'd been in movies he was
in the first nightmare on elm street uh
back in 1985 but you know that was like
a small role it wasn't a major role so
this was um actually tim burton and
johnny depp's first collaboration
and i guess i've heard differing things
but i think that tim burton
wanted johnny depp like he that was like
his first pick right although
this okay this blows my mind and i'm
trying to imagine an alternate universe
where each of these actors was in this
movie instead of johnny depp and how
that would have gone
so what ended up happening
tim burton was actually working with
warner brothers right because he made
peewee's big adventure he made
beetlejuice
and they were kind of like okay well
what what's the next movie you want to
do like he made batman and then that was
like a massive success so he pretty much
just got carte blanche to do whatever he
wanted uh warner brothers were like hey
why don't you do batman 2 or beetlejuice
2 and he's like no i don't want to do
that i want to do edward scissorhands
but then it ended up that
warner brothers like sold the rights to
20th century fox so he goes over to 20th
century fox 20th century fox says well
you can have creative control but
we want edward scissorhands to be played
by tom cruise yeah
and so tim burton was like uh
he's like i met with tom cruise
and he's like it
i love the diplomatic way he put this
he's like he wasn't uh my ideal he's
like but we did meet he's like he was
interesting yeah but he had a lot of
questions also tom cruise wanted there
to be a happy ending
i just can't imagine
because okay so the thing about edward
scissorhands the character
is that he's supposed to be
this gentle
child-like
naive like good-hearted
you know person
you know he's not a real person he's
like an artificial man but you know what
i'm saying
and um you know and i think johnny is
dead yeah i think johnny depp like plays
that so well
i don't think tom cruise could have
pulled it off because tom cruise as i've
said before
every single role he plays he comes off
as a cocky [ __ ] and i think he would
have come off as a cocky [ __ ] and it
wouldn't have worked because you can't
have this had to be a completely
innocent
child-like
sweet
person that's and i don't think tom
cruise could have played that
um so i think tom cruise fans would have
wanted to even see that
no i can't even imagine what that would
have looked like no um you know i
understand what the studio wanted they
wanted some box office draw sure i did
it that wouldn't have happened with tom
cruise in this movie no not at all these
fans would have seen that movie go mad
movie sucked they wouldn't like it it
would have been awful yeah it would have
been awful he's just not you know people
are type cast and tom well i mean some
people have everybody has strengths and
weaknesses you know i'm not [ __ ] on
like i'm not a big fan of tom cruise but
i'm not [ __ ] on him in other movies
because i've seen him in other movies
that i liked him in his hot character
[ __ ] love yeah but but in this world
yeah i did too but it's like in this
role that absolutely would not have
worked because he would have he just he
comes across as too cocky
now he's the wrong guy he's got the
wrong fan base yeah that too you can't
bring his fans to this movie they
wouldn't get it no no um some other
actors that uh were approached were gary
oldman who that might that might have
been okay
um tom hanks no i don't think that would
have worked um who else uh
john cusack he might have been able to
do it particularly around this time
period because john cusack was very like
you know he was in better off dead he
was in say anything so he was very good
at playing like the awkward but
good-hearted guy like he went on and did
like you know horror and stuff later one
other actor i think that could have
pulled this off in those days christian
slater
he probably could have done it back then
i don't know it might have been to nick
jack nicholson
well that's what he was doing just in
that one movie i mean he was
impersonating jack nicholson and
heather's yeah yeah
he did that in a couple of those movies
he did yeah um
i think he could have done it though i
think he understood maybe i think he
understood the goths
yeah
and could have done that style but i
honestly i really i now that it's you
know now that it's this many years later
i can't imagine anyone but johnny depp
in it just because
and johnny depp um when he got the
script he [ __ ] loved it and he really
really wanted to do it and
what he did was he knew that that he
didn't have a lot of dialogue
so he'd have to convey a lot with his
like facial expressions and his eyes and
stuff like that so he went on like a
silent movie thing like he watched like
charlie chaplin and he watched like all
this other stuff because he's like i
wanted to
uh learn how to evoke sympathy without
saying anything and i think that he
really really pulled that off so well i
mean i cannot imagine anybody else in
that role yeah well the tim burton
johnny depp alliance probably started
around this time this was their first
movie together yes uh
[ __ ] burton used him from there on
out and
you know
tim burton can be kind of formulaic in a
way
in some way you can really feel his
style
but man he came up with some good movies
man edwards oh [ __ ] man that was a
[ __ ] guy yeah um
what was the other one [ __ ] freaking
sweeney todd yeah just he had a lot of
now some of them were kind of yeah i
didn't really wasn't a big fan of willy
wonka uh i wasn't either i did not also
i didn't like alice in wonderland i
didn't even see it
it wasn't that good i didn't like it
yeah but uh there was you know
his
tim burton's hits are hits
so i can you know and they're timeless
is another thing christmas real good um
yeah he's good i would have liked to
have seen superman with nick cage
that would have been bad [ __ ] crazy yeah
i saw some of the models but maybe in a
super awesome way i saw some of the
models for it it just looked [ __ ]
that that would have either been the
most awesome thing ever or the most
ridiculous thing ever maybe both of
those things at once i'm actually not
sure
but it's just it's funny to think about
like i said in 1990 before you know goth
had really been mainstreamed or anything
like that like everyone knew what it was
to make a movie like this
and this movie was actually very
successful it cost uh 20 million to make
and it made almost 90 million back uh so
you know the studio was very happy
you know so because and even when they
were first like showing it to test
audiences and stuff overwhelmingly a
positive response so you know they felt
a lot better about it i mean the thing
about it is that
it's just it's just such a great like
fairy tale and it's a great kind of
homage to old monster movies
and it's really i kind of feel like
other than maybe big fish which was
later on um this might be tim burton's
most
personal movie he's talking about
himself it's also kind of an homage to
americana you're forgetting that too
this movie is very very american it's
almost like on
along the lines of the [ __ ] back to
the future [ __ ]
uh uh
trilogy very american feel to it i like
it yeah just yeah just because of him
coming down to suburbia and like i said
i like the fact that they didn't
necessarily
he didn't necessarily demonize suburbia
um because like i said when he came down
there you know
everything was through was from edward's
point of view
so he so he was seeing things like
everything was like bright and [ __ ] like
that and he was like wow look at all
this you know because he had never seen
anything like that before
it's tim burton depicting mundanes yeah
but like i said they weren't bad people
and he and he said and he said the same
thing he's like i didn't he's like i
just i find it a weird place he's like
it's not a bad place necessarily like
the people aren't evil or anything like
that but he just found it very strange
like the way they acted and it's kind of
like they kind of show that in the film
like in a comedic but in a i like that
the comedy in this is like
subtle you know what i mean it's not
like super over the top zany like
you know where everyone's caricatures
it's very um you know it's a little bit
exaggerated but not that much you know
like everybody's having the barbecue and
every you know everybody's like calling
with the curlers and the hair and with
the avon lady and all this other kind of
stuff it's just and i like that going to
work at the same time going to work at
the same time and i really like
particularly peg diane wiest's character
who's the one who adopts him essentially
she is like the nicest person in the
world so he's not saying that you know
even when
later on
in the movie when he actually
gets you know arrested because he's set
up by you know jim
by jim who is uh you know one of the
writers uh boyfriend character played by
anthony michael hall and this was also
the first uh big beefy jock roll that
anthony michael hall had played because
prior to this like i said he'd been in
all the you know all the teen movies the
john hughes movies where he always
played like a dork yeah and so seeing
him in this
was kind of like i remember seeing him
in this and being like holy [ __ ] that's
the same dude yeah anthony michael hall
[ __ ] after he's like after his
steroid cycle
yeah you know [ __ ] um
he
it's funny to see anthony michael hall
just appears a hug
that's what i mean and i i'm pretty sure
i remember like
he's a very attractive guy and [ __ ]
women liked him and on the back of that
he started getting a bunch of other work
and then he ended up doing um
the one where he was the psychic with
the dead zones yeah the dead zone series
which is which is awesome by the way
yeah it's a good series we own it and
that's looking that's hall at the at his
most hunkiest yeah in that one he plays
a great douchebag yeah because he's a
really a douchebag in this one he's a
dick yeah real dick which is not that
was out of character for him you know
and make sure he wasn't typecast but no
i respect hall's work hall's work is
[ __ ] really good yeah he's great in
this um he's just he's so hateable but
like i said
to go from being in all the john hughes
movies and being like this kind of
lovable geek
and then showing up in this one just
suddenly being this big hunky football
player he was just like a total douche
yeah and he he really pulled it off yep
he really pulled it off hats off to him
yeah and uh and like i said you know his
subsequent stuff like the dead zone
series and stuff like that he's [ __ ]
great and all that stuff yeah so and
it's just funny you see us getting a
little dude from [ __ ] weird science
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] he and breakfast
club yeah yeah he [ __ ] turned out to
be just a big handsome dude so yeah like
i said holy [ __ ] man but like i said
it's you know that's this movie was kind
of the start of the start of that yeah
and um i had forgotten you you wanted
this is crazy but i hadn't seen this
movie in such a long time and spoiler
alert spoiler alert incoming spoiler um
i had forgotten that jim anthony michael
hall's character dies at the end
yeah that's right i had totally
forgotten about it yeah it kind of looks
like murder but no it was really defense
of others and it was an accident yeah i
mean edward didn't really mean to he
backed up and fell out the window on his
own yeah i mean well he edward did kind
of stab him in the stomach but he didn't
actually that was just a poke yeah and
he didn't actually mean to he was just
because he was uh smacking winona ryder
around yeah what's happened was defense
of others yeah so he fell out but
honestly like i said you know when i was
talking about tom cruise earlier where
he was like oh we need a happy ending
like so i assume that like oh jim can't
die or you know edward and you know kim
who's uh one in writer's character end
up together i'm like see that wouldn't
have worked though because the whole
point was that he had to go back and
he had experienced the world the world
had kind of turned against him he was
safer back where he was in his own
little domain or whatever so something
really big had to happen
you know for him to be left alone
because that's what happens like jim
gets he dies like at the castle like he
falls out the window and then kim just
comes back to the townspeople with a
spare scissor hand and said oh he's dead
so
leave him alone this uh movie i would
say i would put this movie that this was
our generation's
version it was like our generations of
the goth version of [ __ ] rebel
without a cause
yeah might have been he knows that
very similar
but done by tim burton it's like a
universal monster pitch pitcher but it's
it's rebel without a cause gothic
rebel without a cause
it's just yeah it's just
i just really really liked re-watching
because everything about this is just so
magical yeah you know what i mean
yeah i love like the whole christmas
setting of it like all the ice
sculptures and like with all the snow
and everything like that it's [ __ ]
great and it's hilarious too because you
know like i said they shot this in tampa
in florida i saw some behind the scenes
footage
uh they said well we could only shoot
for like little chunks of time a day
because of the love bugs yeah and i was
like
yeah it's dead season i feel that yeah
well yeah because we've been moving into
our new house the whole front it's just
there's bugs everyone love bugs
everywhere they don't bite or anything
like that but they call them love bugs
in case you didn't know because they're
constantly like they're [ __ ] they're
they're constantly [ __ ] and they fly
around with their butts together like
that they fly around like a damn swarm
and they're everywhere i mean you have a
thing where you have to go to like the
car wash they have special stuff like to
get it all off the front of your car
because it's just but you there's pasted
bugs it means the paint on your car it
eats off the paint and it's just like
it's crazy so it's only a couple weeks
about a couple weeks i think they're out
it depends um honestly they're out now
and it seems like later than usual
because usually it's summertime because
usually i remember july or august uh
where they're swarming and stuff but
yeah so cows
yeah it's just it's insane and there's
like just big [ __ ] swarms up
sometimes they have signs like you know
visibility because of the love bugs it's
that there's that many it's like a
[ __ ] plague
but uh but yeah so some of the behind
the scenes footage was just
us all over the [ __ ] shot and it's
like that you know what are you gonna do
you can't really do anything about that
also the costume that johnny depp had to
wear obviously was making like leather
and latex and [ __ ] like that and they
said it was so hot that johnny depp like
particularly of scenes where he had to
like eat or run or something like that
they said he was just constantly like
throwing up and because the heat was
yeah i mean i can't imagine he must have
lost like 20 pounds in sweat yeah well
he weighs 120 in the movie he looks like
me that's yeah he's very thin well like
i said he was very young at this point
like you know he wasn't the big star
that he is now but yeah it's just i'm
just so happy i got to like rewatch this
because i hadn't seen it for so long and
even though i loved this movie back in
the day it was one of those ones where
it's like oh i kind of like you know tim
burton's other ones from this period
better but now that i'm watching it
again like with a slightly different
perspective because i'm slightly older i
was like i don't know i think this might
be i i still think edward is probably my
favorite but
this is this has gone like way up like
in his uh in his canon for me just
because i don't know i just love the
whole feel of it it's such a even though
it's dark like the particularly the
ending is kind of dark
but
i don't know i just like the whole fairy
tale feel of it i just like how you know
like i said i just like how magical it
is i like it better than beetlejuice
really yeah i like a better beetlejuice
i yeah it's you know i wasn't a big fan
of you i mean i liked beetlejuice but
just come on
beetlejuice is a little too silly for me
sometimes it is yeah beetlejuice is
zanier
uh this one is a lot more i like this
one because it's kind of gentler like
the humor is subtler it's not as wacky
right because it's not you know it's not
dealing with like supernatural kind of
[ __ ] yeah so maybe yeah maybe that's i
see what you're saying i see what you
said i love people it's up there with
his grace it's up there with mars
attacks it's up there with you yeah i
mean seriously if you haven't seen
edward scissorhands i kind of feel like
everyone's seen edward scissorhands but
there's a lot of youngsters that haven't
seen that if you haven't seen it's just
so good and i think it holds up like
really really well and especially if you
grew up like and you felt like a weirdo
yeah um i think you'll really like
relate and i think that's like a
universal only thing that might be
missing is kind of the nine to five
suburbia motif i'm not sure how much
that still exists
true a lot of those jobs that those
people worked back in those days you
know during my dad's era and everything
they're they're they're they're gone
yeah those companies are gone those jobs
are kind of gone
you know even in the neighborhood that
we live in now they're not all late
leaving at exactly the same time there's
shifts and stuff and there's
i think a lot of them are working from
home i guess it just depends yeah
there's still a rush hour
on i-4 yeah so it's like oh everyone's
stopped must be five o'clock so there is
some of that [ __ ] going on it's just
that it's not as generic as it used to
be yeah it's not as regimented as it
used to be i mean but i remember it as a
kid it was almost like damn near it's
like something you'd see out of japan or
it was very uniformed yeah very uniform
but that's what i mean it's like but i
think that even younger people even if
they haven't experienced that i think
because it's idealized in the movie
that's true
um then you can kind of fit it for any
time like is it it could be the 50s it
could be the 70s it could be it could be
anything because it's not the motif i
get i was saying is 50s it's not it's
probably more like early 60s like
i think it's supposed to look like 64 65
yeah it's like they don't really say
well i guess it's supposed to be like a
long time ago because it's a wrap around
story um it's basically winona ryder
she's a grandma now and she's telling
about this happening in her past when
she was a teenager
so
but like i said it's a fairy tale so the
time doesn't really matter so it's
almost kind of like yeah like an
idealized
early 60s like california suburb where
all the houses were looked exactly the
same there was one of four colors all
the women track housing yeah all the all
the women were kind of wearing those
kind of like pedal pushers and stuff
like that where so yeah that very like
early 60s because i remember seeing my
grandma like wearing wearing outfits
like that i saw some urban exploration
stuff around here in florida and uh
in
those neighborhoods like they used in
this movie they have one then they go
and it's abandoned there's a lot of them
that are abandoned yeah yeah the urban
exploration shows and you go in there
it's funny they're all look like that
and they're all the same size and the
same layout and it's got street lights
it looks
it looks old but it looks in good
condition you know what i mean it looks
like nobody's moved into it and they're
looking into the windows and they're all
just empty and it's been empty for you
know 15 years
some company bought the land and just
shut it down they're probably gonna
build something on it later
crazy it's just funny to think that
these neighborhoods are gone a lot of
them yeah well you know time passes time
passes stuff you know they build houses
things go to style areas go out of style
you know it's just that's what happens
constantly moving but yeah so if you
have hulu this is actually on hulu at
the moment which is where i watched it
but i'm sure you can get it other places
too i'm sure it's [ __ ] everywhere
because this is
a classic and honestly
i just the second time i watched this
this recent time i watched it i just
loved everything about it i had such a
great time with it i love all the
suburbia characters uh particularly
joyce kathy baker's character she's
[ __ ] great the cougar yeah she's
hilarious and uh you know just everybody
has to orgasm when he's cut
right now she's
like that she's her feet
yeah that's fine i just love it
everybody in this is like so so good
everybody in it is just like perfectly
perfectly cast but yeah so seriously if
you haven't seen it
see it it's easily one of tim burton's
best movies
and uh you'll love it i promise if you
don't uh i don't know your money back i
don't know
anyway so uh we will be back next time
for another movie retrospective
thanks for watching
bye
you